a lot of people think it's it's
basically digital gold because it's so
scarce it holds value well and you can
transfer it instantly I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer friesen TV and today I'm
talking with John Holmquist he's the
marketing director for Bitcoin store and
we've heard a lot about Bitcoin in the
news lately and I want to put it in
context outside of this abstract notion
of decentralized currency and how can
factor into all manner of goods and
services John thanks for talking to us
thank you for inviting me so you were in
an online retail store that sells
hundreds of thousands of electronics and
you primarily accept Bitcoin as payment
so talk about the store a little bit and
how these transactions work the reason
that we're accepting bitcoin is payment
is because it allows us to eliminate
most fees that you get from payment
processing companies which allows us to
actually undercut a lot of major online
retailers who you're used to paying with
dollars so it adds a direct financial
incentive for people to use Bitcoin
could you put that in real numbers for
us like what those incentives look like
it's anywhere between one to ten percent
there's a lot of costs that coming that
come with using a payment process or
paypal charges something like three
percent just every transaction bitcoin
is an investment opportunity but it's
also a lot more liquid than other
investments so can you say can you talk
about why bitcoin might be a good
alternative to putting your money
elsewhere it's it's an interesting
concept because it's it's an investment
its currency some people might call it a
commodity and like you said it as liquid
but it's also very volatile it's very
risky I don't recommend many people
invest in it it's very complicated and
takes a lot of knowledge to accurately
predict where it's going to go how do
you think Bitcoin star will change the
overall landscape of the online retail
market the goal is to pressure retailers
like amazon newegg walmart to start
accepting Bitcoin simply because we're
able to undercut them by using Bitcoin
only so if they begin accepting Bitcoin
they're able to pocket that one two
three percent that their paint a Visa
and MasterCard and there's really no
reason for them not to they just needed
a working example showing exactly how
much money that couldn't soon we can
save if this catches on how could it
expand beyond the online market I've
heard talks of like Bitcoin
atms there are a lot of questions about
whether bitcoin can use in the real
world it takes a while to actually
confirm bitcoin transactions so i heard
a story of a fellow that was buying gold
in arizona at a store that accepted
bitcoin he had to wait around for about
hour Willy waited for his bitcoins to
confirm before they'd actually give him
the gold so in its current state I don't
see Bitcoin being used too much in the
real world but with the infrastructure
of Bitcoin growing I can see payment
processors basically existing on top of
the Bitcoin network providing payments
that are a lot quicker so do you think
once we move past this learning curve it
could become more mainstream you have to
realize that bitcoins less than four
years old it's still even it's in beta
it's never actually gotten into a
release version so it's still very new I
can't really remember how many people
are using email after four years but
it's something that still needs to be
developed a lot Bitcoin has gotten a
little bit of a bad rap because of its
affiliation with the black market and
silk road how does Bitcoin store and
similar retail sites how would this
combat this image the Bitcoin economy is
growing before this last month the Silk
Road was a significant portion of the
Bitcoin economy with this last month
we've seen a large amount of retailers
posting huge amounts of sales and the
sum of the total is actually eclipsing
the Silk Road and any commerce that
they're doing as it grows I can only see
the Bitcoin economy that's legitimate
growing much much bigger than a Silk
Road ever was or ever will be do you
think bitcoins current model of
decentralized currency will inspire
competing currencies yes I don't think
that bitcoin is the end-all solution it
implemented a lot of innovative ideas
that were never seen before it was very
revolutionary at the same time though
it's it's not the end product there are
still advances to be made there's still
a lot of problems nothing that's too
difficult to solve but a lot of people
question whether Bitcoin as it exists
now is a good solution to the problems
of trying to solve if you could go a
little more in depth on what a
hypothetical electronic currency run
economy looks like it's a lot cheaper
you don't have to pay the middle men
with
be payment processors banks governments
it opens up a lot of global trade that
can happen I'm able to send right now at
a singapore any amount of money really
with little to no fees the amount of
international commerce that happens
inside the bitcoin economy is actually
staggering i can only see it growing and
one of the things that bitcoin is really
good at doing is moving transfer that's
why a lot of people think it's it's
basically digital gold because it's so
scarce it holds value well and you can
transfer it instantly unlike gold John
thanks again for coming in thank you for
having me friesen TV I'm Tracy
Oppenheimer